what's going on man oh how's it going
i'm good how are you brother
you know i'm i got i got covet so
that's a little not great but other than
that
you know and it's the kind that it's
like really mild so i'm feeling like a
little
tickly in the throat but
and i guess i cough but uh aside from
that i'm i'm good
happy new year
happy new year to you too it's good to
see i'm glad that you're that you're on
the mend and that it was that it was
mild
like uh but you're at like
almost peak seamless strength right now
you're at like
95 percent peak siemens strength right
now yeah yeah we'll say
define define peak semen strength was
that what would that be like peak like
i'm shooting the movie i'm working out
five times a week because if that's peak
senior strength i'd be like at a 40.
look
as long as you'll be good to go
for these junos man like then we're
we're good we're excited tell me about
this tell me about how this all
came to be how excited were you at the
opportunity to do this oh my god i was
so excited well i guess it's star i mean
i guess my relationship with the juno
started uh back in 2019
i had a fun little uh presenting gig in
my alma mater city of london ontario
and um i got to i got to be there for
the ceremony i got to watch sarah
mclachlan host uh who's absolutely
transcendent and incredible
um and then kind of from there i feel
like you know a couple things happened
in my career i don't know if you've
heard about it um i may i may have been
around for some of that yeah movie yeah
anyway um
so some things happened and then all of
a sudden you know um the junos reached
out and they said would you would you
consider hosting and i was like
absolutely yes
um i was like would you like me to
perform also and they were like no
that's that's okay just the hosting and
i was like are you sure and they're like
yeah um
so i was like okay fine fine just put
just a little stick then um
but i mean i you know my favorite year i
always
re-watched these videos on youtube but
the year that drake hosted i thought was
so funny i thought he made the junos
into something that was
like it was just so much fun to tune
into and and he had like a lloyd
robertson cameo
and
justin bieber he was skyping with justin
bieber and i was just like this is great
this is comedic gold and and so um
you know i think i think that the junos
has a high caliber of comedy even even
though it's a celebration of canadian
music as it should be
but a high caliber for its hosts
well i mean it's fair to say that in the
tradition of
canadian awards shows and hosting
canadian awards shows comedy is always a
big aspect of it i am surprised though
that they turned down the opportunity to
have you perform we know you can sing we
know you got the pipes man oh man
if you if you were gonna get the
opportunity to actually duet on stage
with anybody that's you know any
canadian musician who would you want to
do that with oh my god have you ever
seen that viral video of michael buble
he's like doing a concert and he brings
like a random kid on stage and the kid
just starts like
you know i would like to do that i would
love to surprise michael buble
with one of his own songs
that would be the best
i would i would pay to see that
i'm not gonna lie i would i would love
to see that that would be incredible
amazing amazing
so listen i mean you you mentioned very
briefly that you know you worked on this
little project that people might know
you for um
legend of ten rings it may have saved
cinema in our modern time who knows
right oh no i mean yeah it depends on
who you ask some people say we just kept
it warm until spider-man showed up but
uh you know
you're all you're on the same team
you're all on the same team it's all
fair same team we're on the same team
yeah you know you're um
your 2021 was pretty
spectacular man like
to put it mildly
do you look at 2022 and go man how am i
how i'm gonna top this how are we gonna
top this you know that carlos that's an
excellent question i actually
i'm so excited for 2022. um you know
when i look back in the year that i had
it was just so much go go go it was so
many like new and exciting experiences
but ultimately just
so much anxiety of like you know first
of all just the physical travel of it
all like the lift that that comes with
just having to be in so many different
places at once and then also to deal
with all of the new stimulus you know
coming into your brain i mean it's a lot
it's great um but it's also you know it
it wears and tears on you a little bit
mentally and
i'm actually and i'm not joking you i'm
not
i'm looking forward to not trying to top
anything i'm looking forward to having a
2022 that is that is very me focused in
terms of like mental health and and my
well-being um
and uh and and you know i'm sure it'll
end up being all of the crazy and hectic
things that 2021 was but um if you were
to ask me right now what my what i'm
most looking forward to it's it's i
think just like resting a little bit and
getting into the groove and figuring
this whole thing out whatever it is
taking the time uh for myself
so you recently finished shooting a
movie with mark wahlberg and we know
about his like
like wake up at like two or three in the
morning kind of like get started on the
day work out super early routine did you
incorporate any of that number one into
your routine
and number two is he like competitive
when it comes to being
like physically fit are you is it one of
those things where you're like hey i
just rattled off uh 40 chinups he's like
yeah i i can do 41. like what is it like
in in that sense
you know i'm gonna i'll say this he he
knows how to level the playing field
so i
i
and and to be fair okay so i mean
otherworldly uh you know discipline
you know getting up that early yeah
exactly like 2 30 a.m 3 a.m that all
happened
but you know we'd show up on set and and
i'll be like mark how's your morning
like oh that's great i worked i worked
out i was on three business calls uh i
started i started a small business i
sold the script and and now i'm here and
i'm like great i woke up half an hour
ago as the car was pulling into set and
uh
and that's that's my day
um
so i i did work out with him one time
though because i was like i'm gonna kick
myself by if i don't at least try to do
just just the once i'm not gonna work it
i'm not gonna wake up at 3 a.m every day
but just
one time i want to do the thing and so i
show up and i'm like you know i consider
myself like pretty strong pretty good
shape and he's like welcome
and then he and then he's like here i
got these bands for you
i'm like what are you talking about he's
like no you're gonna put these bands on
your arms to like cut off the
circulation
because it's not enough to work out at 2
30 in the morning you have to do it
while depriving your body of oxygen so
he like puts the bands around my arms
and he tightens them and he's like okay
now do the weights
and i'm like i can't
i can't lift anything he's like yeah
that's right that's your body like he's
he you know he goes on and on about how
these bands are are like amazing for you
and to be fair they did feel amazing
after the fact
but while it was going on it was like me
trying to lift like five pounds with
these with these like tourniquets
attached to my arms and i was just like
what is happening
and he's and he's just kind of in the
corner laughing at me so so um
you know i don't i don't know is he
competitive is does he just does he just
rigged the game um
yeah you gotta ask him
i like that it's like he's kind of like
uh he's gokuing it a little bit he's got
the weights on the entire time you
didn't realize yeah and when he takes
him off he's like he just goes
i don't know man i think like you know
without the bands though with the band's
draw i think you know i
i think we're i think we're
we're the same conversation of
fitness level
i hear you i hear you
[Laughter]
so i was looking at um hey the reason
why i knew that you had got a case of
the omicron a little bit because that
was a recent post that you did and i
thought it was interesting one of the
you know you see the comments underneath
and uh and one of them was like ken john
and like just basically like wishing you
well and to me i think that's like
like i look at that i'm like
that's amazing like ken jong and you got
like you guys are tight you're having
conversation to you when you look at
your either your comments or your dms
and it's people that you
in the last few years have gotten to
know and actually have a relationship
with like how wild is it to you
that this is a thing and who is it like
what name pops up
in either messaging you or whatever that
you go whoa like i can't believe i'm
about to respond to this human being
right now
right i mean that that oh my god first
of all that happens so many times ken is
a little bit different ken is my um ken
is my primary care physician so is
legally obligated to wish me well um
and you know he knows my body better
than i've seen every inch
he's a doctor doctor um
you know when the movie came out i mean
it i i ran the gamut like like everybody
reached out and and it was people that i
was like how are you talking to me right
now you know i i literally feel like i
just watched you on a big screen um but
the general just i mean i mean the
general justice everybody is is just
kind of so happy about about the moment
and really enthusiastic i don't want to
want to like
point anybody out i mean i'm sure he
wouldn't mind if i said but uh tom
hiddleston has been wonderful
sent an awesome note um
you know chris pratt
tom holland they were all you know very
very wonderful and supportive
and then i'll see in the movie which is
which is amazing you know you don't you
don't always have to do that um
but uh
it was it definitely pinched me moments
to to receive you know messages of
support and well wishes from all of them
any of those names you just mentioned
have a
opportunity to be cameoing in the next
change
you're good you're damn it you're good
um i
know i don't i don't know anything i
don't know we just announced the sequel
i haven't even i haven't even had my my
first meeting yet um we we know i'm just
as much in the dark as as everyone else
so
gonna
ask me again in a few months and i'll
tell you the same
listen i know but myself and uh the
audience at large is going to be very
happy to go along that ride with you man
i'm really excited uh you know
especially i think it's like i felt the
same way about king's convenience but
like the first year you do it
you're just so nervous and you're so
focused on not messing up that you
forget that you you can also do a good
job like you know what i mean um
but when you now that we know we're
coming back in a way um i just feel so
excited because i feel like i'm so much
more settled so much more
in in myself you know so i'm really
excited to kind of bring that level of
of just like
confidence to the to the character to my
work and
hopefully you know it'll translate on
screen and people will like it
right on man hey thank you so much for
taking the time
always great catching up with you
yeah i hope you've been working on your
basketball game buddy
i will say i will say i've been sinking
a lot of you know just trash can bucket
shots all morning right yeah so
i mean that's something
it's something it's i don't know if it's
basketball but it's something
i don't hold myself to high standard i
don't know yes you know this all right
man
you